welcome to weapons training now for a
little target practice
we're teleporting pistols to the
holsters at your hips look down and
observe every time you draw a pistol
Robo ready supply team receives a
requisition request they will teleport
new pistols to you as soon as possible
so check your holsters often now you're
armed just squeeze the trigger to shoot
agent 34 we are getting reports of a hot
spot in the city where multiple Robo
ready products have gone rogue
please note product defects are always
the result of user air from already not
responsible it's time to test your
recall skills in the field please hold
for teleport welcome to your first
mission agent 34 lookout agent incoming
Here I am
agent there's a defective bot grab the
white ring now observe that the product
has multiple white rings anything with
multiple white rings can be torn apart
grab a second white ring and try it now
excellent work always keep an eye out
for multiple white rings when you're
holding something
we're teleporting pistols to the
holsters at your hips a defective
product
the alley
agent more crawlers use elevation
hi
fight your way up the alley
Wow
that was a smooth recall keep moving
down the alley
juggle
[Music]
van will teach oh is this yeah nothing
hey Ali
you
agent we're teleporting weapons to your
back bolsters your shoulders 34
can you clear this area
while you were busy recalling we had an
uptake of rogue robots in this hot spot
will lead you to recall as many as you
can quickly three two
it wasn't using good anyway
[Music]
an aspirin he's got a headache
see
move to the next objective be careful
agent 34 sensors indicate something
large heading your way
lookout agent incoming
is dangerous duck underneath it
[Music]
he's down teleportal talk to him and
take control you can take control of his
this and laser
lasered
[Music]
making friends
[Music]
nice cooking
I was there
Hey
cook-out
your weapons have gone offline
new record
thank you for playing
you